THIS POLICY FOR DECADES.
>> Laura: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR COMING.
THE TRAY QUIZ IS COMING LATER.
BY THE WAY, THERE WAS A CURIOUS
DEVELOPMENT DURING THE SHUTDOWN.
ONE I KNOW THAT SOME OF YOU SAW
BECAUSE YOU TWEETED ME ABOUT IT.
MSNBC AND CHUCK SUMER ON
DIFFERENT OCCASIONS GOING
AFTER YOURS TRULY FOR HOLDING
THE LINE, AS I HAVE FOR MANY,
SIT, SOME PEOPLE WOULD SAY
SUPPORTED BY OTHERS AND OTHERS
WOULD SAY TERRORIZED BY NEWS
OUTLETS BY BREITBART OR
LAURA INGRAHAM.
>> Laura: TERRORIZING?
TELL ME SHE'S NOT CALLING ME OUT
FOR TERRORIZING HOUSE MEMBERS?
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME CASEY
HUNT MENTIONED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO ACTUALLY DO
TERRORIZE AMERICAN CITIZENS.
WE WILL GET TO THIS AND A FEW
SEGMENTS.
MS-13 AND WHAT THEY ARE DOING
TWO AREAS RIGHT OUTSIDE OF HERE.
ROVING GAINS OF RUTHLESS
CRIMINALS WHO ARE TERRORIZING
AMERICAN CITIZENS >> Laura:
OFFENDERS OF MULTIPLE
DEPORTATION STOPPER ENTERING THE
COUNTRY AND TERRORIZING OUR
PEOPLE, THAT'S WHEN I WILL STOP
TERRORIZING CONGRESSMAN ABOUT
THE ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SPEAKING OF TERROR,
CHUCK SCHUMER ACTUALLY SUGGESTED
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS ABOUT TO
SIGN ON TO THE GRAHAM DURBIN
DACA DEAL UNTIL BIG BAD LAURA
SHOWED UP.
>> THE HARD RIGHT CAME AFTER HIM
>> THE HARD RIGHT CAME AFTER HI
HIM.
BREITBART CALLS HIM AMNESTY
TRUMP.
LAURA INGRAHAM HAM INSISTED HE
WOULD BE IMPEACHED.
BY THE WEEKEND, HE HAD BACKED
OFF.
>> Laura: NOT ONLY HAS HE BEEN
EMBARRASSED TODAY WITH HIS
POLITICAL INEPTITUDE, NOW
CHUCK SCHUMER IS JUST FLAT OUT
LYING.
I NEVER, EVER SAID THAT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
HE MUST BE CONFUSING ME BECAUSE
I DON'T KNOW MAKE A BREZINSKI OR
SOMETHING.
I HAVE NO IDEA.
I SAID THE PRESIDENT BASE WOULD
BE WATCHING THE DACA DEAL VERY
CLOSELY AND THEY WOULDN'T STAND
FOR AMNESTY.
YOU KNOW WHAT, THEY OBVIOUSLY
WON'T AND WOULDN'T.
I ALSO SET ON THE SHOW THAT THE
PRESIDENTS ENEMIES WANT HIM
IMPEACHED.
I SAID THAT FROM THE BEGINNING.
CHUCK, I SUGGEST YOU GET A
BETTER STRATEGY TEAM AND YOU GET
YOUR FACTS STRAIGHT.
DON'T PUT WORDS IN MY MOUTH.